[Music]
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about media
livestreams drones and so much more we
have Eddie Cadell joining us on the show
hello thanks for having me thanks so
much for coming on Eddie we're really
excited for this episode you and Ron
have been great friends for a long time
and I'm really glad to have been
introduced to you and your long long
time of work in this field really
excited to unpack this together for
those who don't know Eddie Cadell is a
media and live stream producer drone
pilot and founder of the flying robot
International Film Festival and you can
find the links in the Bible o to Eddie
calm as well as his youtube channel and
his Twitter profile and you let's start
things off with one of our favorite
questions to ask our guests what are
your thoughts in the direction of our
world direction of our world it's
rotational right don't mean a don't we
revolve around the Sun I think it's it's
in orbit direction I mean that's that's
the that's the right answer but the or
the that's the scientific answer you
know I think we're gonna survive the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that's going on in the
world right now I I want to believe that
the institutions that we have created
will outlast the individuals who who
inhabit them and and and and so I'm just
gonna leave with that what do you think
are some of the key principles that we
need to embody to make sure that we make
it compassion understanding going to
other places so I think a big problem
with people with Americans is they don't
travel you know we get so like locked up
in their own world you know I feel like
yeah being able to understand other
people really is the big thing yeah
that's huge we recently also learned
that about us apparently 1.3 out of the
1.4 billion people in China also haven't
left China yet so it's kind of correct
yes and I don't mean to say you know
being very us centric I you know not it
can't really speak for the rest of the
world but obviously
there's a lot of you don't even have the
opportunity to do so but I think those
who are who have the ability to affect
the way this world can you know I think
climate change is the biggest issue we
have facing us right now and you know
the u.s. is going to be the you know one
of the countries that's instrumental in
deciding how that fate is going to play
out and so we do have a lot of
responsibility and how we how we proceed
yeah
Ron is our logo oh my god Ronnie let's
the world is the world stopping let's
get that no but there it is I love it
okay so that was on direction of our
world let's do journey okay so actually
you told me you're born in London which
is really interesting spent the first
five years they're not first five years
in Europe and on linear list yeah yeah
what was that like well it's really
young at the time so I don't remember a
whole lot but so I was in London for a
year I was in Switzerland Geneva for I
think a couple years and then in Denmark
for a period of time so my mother's
Danish my father is an American they met
in Africa in the 60s they had me in the
late 60s in in London my dad was I was
working was a journalist for the America
The Associated Press at the time he was
international correspondent so he had
just been relocated to to the London
office at the time that I was born and
and then at some point we ended up
moving to Geneva I think he was he ended
up yeah his job ended up moving him
there so moved there my sister was born
there and then at some point we came
back to the States
when I was yeah around four or five I
lived in my grandparents down in Florida
at the time west palm beach you and if
the only time I've ever lived there I've
been there actually but then we moved up
to the north Northern Virginia DC area
when I was five years old and that's
where I grew up is Arlington Virginia
northern DC area and yeah I was there
until until I moved out here in 97 so
all my yeah school and everything was
out there and then so what were some of
those
moments from that's an interesting story
of your mom and dad meeting in Africa
that's a whole nother week yeah I don't
have all the facts on a person correct
on that but I can quickly say that my
father was in the Peace Corps and then
he was a journalist both both in Africa
and Nigeria and in the Congo actually
the Congo is where he was where he met
my mother where he was working as a
journalist and my mother was there at
the time as well but you know there was
a dictator that took over at some point
and so a lot of the Western press was
basically in was was told to leave after
labuda took over power and whatever year
that was 67 68 or something whoa yeah
yeah pretty crazy like my parents have a
really interesting sorted beginning to
their life and then after I came along
they became really boring yeah we but
how did Indy see what was going on with
you growing up that got you interested
in art and film um I mean I've always
been kind of you know I artistically
inclined I guess for just been you know
in into the arts like wouldn't you know
after I know I grafter I graduated
college I worked at the alternative
weekly newspaper in DC for four years
running I was actually running their
network so I was a bit of a nerd and I
you know I am
I knew computer stuff so I was the guy
running there I was the system
administrator which is they called
DevOps these days and the webmaster at
the time so basically managing the whole
infrastructure or the technical
infrastructure for the for the newspaper
and actually just as a quick aside
that's how I ended up coming to
California yeah so my boss at the time
who also was our company the Russian
city paper was the paper I'm talking
about and it was also owned by the the
owners of the city paper also owned the
Chicago Reader that's a time and my boss
who was one of the the owners of the
reader sent me out to California to a
desktop publishing conference in 1996 or
so and that was my first time coming in
California and I was like immediately I
knew I'd already know and prior to that
I probably was a West Coast inclined
person and so I came out here and I did
the full like three four-week drive
around the state camp explore kind of
and you know after the conference was
over and I knew immediately that I was
kidding yeah it was gonna happen so a
year later it happens yeah I love it
yeah what and that's a beautiful way to
do it is to come here and do the whole
four weeks of going around the state
seeing its beauty and also just like you
said that desktop publishing conference
yeah you know here it was the cutting
edge right there at the time and so then
you wanted to kind of gravitated towards
that edge and wanting to be here and
seeing what Silicon Valley was going to
emerge next yeah I mean at the time it
was you know I it kind of there was kind
of a confluence of all the things that
were interesting to me at the time you
know West Coast you know beautiful
beautiful environment laid-back culture
no song no snow that's true the the
winters and these summers were a lot
more reasonable in most parts of the
state here you know the the history of
you know the 60s and the sort of
countercultural movement in the Bay Area
definitely spoke to me on some level and
and in the internet though the rise of
Technology and the internet was was you
know definitely it was was all part of
that and so you know my first job coming
out here was working for a web design
company and I was there sysadmin running
running you know even running their UNIX
systems in there you know the printers
and things like that and yeah and then
that that and I ended up basically
working at a number of companies like
that working as initially as a sysadmin
but then moving into back into
infrastructure our contexture so it
worked as a systems engineer for a
start-up where we would see the last
well anyway but just different startups
doing tech stuff until about I don't
know well it's it's that has been kind
of a thread throughout my whole
existence but I in in those early days
you know I was working as somebody who
was staring at a screen pretty much all
day long and that kind of got ahold
after awhile and so you know I won
something it's a little more exciting a
little more content oriented a little
bit more than some shitty way to say it
but a little bit more you know that had
a little more yeah art to it a little
bit more excitement to it and so you
know and I still love typing away on a
screen for sure but I
I didn't find hanging out in data
centers you know installing systems
where this was a way that wouldn't smell
out of my time and then what was going
on in like 97 to 2007 before you really
got started with the video production
what was happening in the Silicon Valley
then and what happened with the dot-com
right
well my so my first job was was at this
Web Design Studio I was funny about
based in South Park here in San
Francisco and at the time South Park was
the home of it was multimedia Gulch as
what was called a time so at that time
or just prior to that time the beginning
she was making CD ROMs of you know of
anything you think of encyclopedias
Encarta and multimedia sort of
productions of rich content that was the
way to make rich content was to
basically and when we say rich we're
talking about you know maybe 8-bit color
on you know like a Mac plus or something
you know the little fat Mac give me this
is this is you know weight light years
away from what we have today and but
this is what the industry was at the
time was was you know shrink crack
packaged software experiences that were
packaged on CD box and so that was the
area when that was happening at the time
that I showed up the internet was just
becoming a viable medium for for
publishing and advertising actually so
Wired magazine was you know right down
the street and I got to know a lot of
friends who worked there over time and
at Wired and organic which was in the
same building they basically invented
you know they created the first website
create the first rich media websites and
then the first advertising refers banner
ads were created there as well so sort
of the beginning of the commercial web
really I think started in that bad
neighborhood and and I was there to see
a lot of that and so you know we ended
up working for companies that were
building sites for you know before the
for the industry as it was emerging so I
mean I was lucky to sort of participate
and see a lot of the emergence of
various startups I mean I don't know
life a lot of people know this but you
know some of the biggest names in
in you know Silicon Valley tech
companies these days started right there
in South Park so Twitter for example
started right there on South Park as did
Instagram and since I actually have the
same offices as a matter of fact
and so the a lot of that there was just
a lot of like kind of brainpower and
enthusiasm like located right in that
like three block area and you know
taking us all those yeah packaging the
CD ROMs and shrink-wrap and sharing
those around the world and then the just
like complexities around like what we
see now in 2019 is we don't always look
back 10 15 years at what companies used
to be like and that I think gives us a
really unique idea into the journeys
that people take in the journeys that
these organizations end up taking over
periods of more than a decade to try and
provide the world with some sort of a
utility some sort of a good or service
that that makes the world better and and
it's good to see it from that point and
that was also at the time that you
started doing video production actually
you know what it's there's a part that
we that I forgot to mention earlier and
we were just discussing some things so I
one of the things I think he got me into
the more artistic side of things was the
webzine conference which was something
that I was involved in starting in 1997
98 99 2000 2001 and then again in 2005
and what that was was a basically a
day-long or an eventually a 2 day long
conference on independent publishing on
the Internet
so we were you know the initial idea is
that we were kind of an antidote to to
the monetization of eyeballs and the
idea was well let's use the web for
creativity for storytelling for things
that aren't about necessarily making
money community and you know and a lot
of people who were part of the that
those early webzines
went on to you know create amazing
things and big companies and whatever
out of that so I don't know if we
totally won because you know ultimately
in capitalism still it was the big
attractor coming out of that but
ultimately I think what
we what what I realized quickly when
going to work in 97 was that there was
this big push to kind of you know as
there is today there's a lot of people
who are coming in to you know San
Francisco and Silicon Valley to make
their fortune work at a start-up and
make their 16 you know six digit
salaries and and hopefully cash out an
IPO or something that sentiment was very
much live then as well and I think what
we were trying to do with webzine is
provide sort of an alternative to that
to say hey it doesn't have to always be
about you know grinding out 60 hours 80
hours a week to crank it on someone
else's project that may or may not make
you rich but hey maybe you know you
could you can actually just do a side
project do something on your own that
that you're passionate about and so
that's really what webzine was all about
was to create an avenue for that and
that is what got me into the more I
think creative side of things is
actually it was webzine so since we're
talking my webzine I got to give two
quick shout outs to my friend Ryan
Jenelle who was the the motion graphics
creator of the the intro that we just
saw in the beginning there he worked
with me at that very first company that
I worked at a Phoenix pop and then has
been a friend of mine and collaborator
ever since webzines and and in flying
robot actually and then also srini who
is most famous for creating the website
unamerican comm which was a sticker
company and basically they made click
type stickers that would say things like
[ __ ] work or you know I can't remember
the whole yeah but basically there were
slogans right and he he kind of founded
that and is the person who basically who
found the money to create the first
webzine bit he went to Adobe and said
hey we got this great idea for a
community conference can you give us
some money for it and Adobe is like sure
sounds great here's 1500 bucks so we
threw a party for ourselves ninety
united so that is kind of how it started
so thank you Adobe I love the that that
definitely tells a bit on the art in the
community side and also kind of tells a
bit on the interest in decentralization
and open sourcing and these types of
mentalities that are now starting to a
rebuttal up kind of like the
counterculture movement which in many
ways I think is where hopefully that
would that we're heading and that we can
bring together some of these unity
mentalities with us then then did then
in 2006 you were telling us about the
South Park area and how that was kind of
this Gulch of what was it again the
multimedia gulp immediate Gulch and so
you ended up producing a show called
lunch meat right
so both multimedia college was really
during the cd-rom era which I would say
the more about the mid 90s but lunch
meat came around in 2005 so just a back
a little bit I did a thing called geek
entertainment TV which I don't think I
sent any clips of that but that was a
webseries that I started this is yeah
with my friend and collaborator Irina
Slutskaya is the woman
this one right here actually right yeah
they're on the left and then here's the
three right so just just a quick aside
geek entertainment TV was it was a three
or four year project but we went around
and interviewed interesting people
friends start to put it start up
individuals or whatever at parties and
we were kind of more like the
tongue-in-cheek
kind of Daily Show essica that's kind of
where we sort of took our cues from in
some ways a way of approaching this
audience right and so in 2005 the both
of us got hired by a company to make a
video to continue doing our show but
also to make new videos and so one of
the shows that we did was called
lunchmeat l look at lunch meat spelled
eet and it's meeting geeks over lunch
was was sort of lucky so yeah so I
believe this is a head like number
twelve or thirteen and yeah we were we
were meeting the Twitter guys Jack Jack
yeah that's yeah Jack and is there so
they were sort of 2006 this is 2006 the
time right so I think no had been pushed
out and this is in South Park this is in
this is the office that also was the
Instagram office later and so yeah this
is 2006 so I think it hadn't been a year
yet that Twitter was around and
you know we just approach them say hey
can we do you do an interview on on you
know with you guys and they said sure
and and the the sort of the format of
the show was we would interview founders
and then we would do a walk like an
on-camera demo of whatever the product
was so that's what we did here we
interviewed these guys for about a half
half the show and then if you cut to the
next clip and then yeah this is so cool
this is this is what Twitter looked like
in 2006 I think late 2006 and this is
Jack giving us a demo of of Twitter at
the time with his 90 followers 90
followers 123 friends yep and and at the
time you had everybody showed up a
little icon on the side there's a few
interesting things here you could DMing
was this little drop-down box SMS was a
big thing at the time too so you could
actually use you could text to four oh
four oh four and a user name and you
could actually text to using basically
text messaging to send to Twitter yeah
and that eventually went away but that
was an integral part of it for so long
and yeah and in some of it at the time I
think they're the main feed updated like
once every few seconds or once ever you
actually know every few minutes so you
know there were updates when we were
doing the interview because some of the
other employees would go ahead and you
know put a tweet in to sort of you know
show us that something was coming up
live but as you can see Blaine is one of
the early early creators of what I think
was the first engineer there and yeah so
these are all these are all early or
early Twitter people I think what was
really key in 2006 it looks like is that
people started wanting to take the pulse
on what was happening on the planet and
between humans yeah and then that was
kind of where these things emerged
is also if you notice the way these
tweets are coming out they're answering
the prompt what are you doing yeah what
are you doing right yeah which is so it
was a way to prop people to get people
to say something and so you look most
everything is is in response to that
question whereas today people tweet
anything and everything usually you know
promoting something yeah or railing
against something or putting a new
awaken people with conscious content
sure there's plenty of things or
demeaning congresspeople and yeah yeah
in starting wars or potentially getting
the content out that shows the other
perspective when it's trying to be yes
yep it - what about what what about what
was happening in live-streaming at this
time because both you and Ron were
getting involved with live-streaming in
the earlier days right so I got around
the timeframe here
I worked for okay so I worked for a
startup company in 2001 called fast
forward networks that made scalable back
in infrastructure for livestream
technologies so basically it was a way
to broadcast using the Internet in a
very efficient way that company no
longer exists they our biggest
competitor at the time was Akamai which
is now the 800-pound gorilla in that
world but that and this is again when I
was still more on the tech side of
things I didn't really have anything do
with content the time this was all I was
maintaining servers and building systems
and helping to basically build that
infrastructure that that our technology
was was enabling and but in 2005 I
started getting into media production
and so we did geek owner Tim TV for a
few years and then lunchmeat and then I
coming out of lunchmeat one of the
people I interviewed was the CEO of
Ustream at the time Jon Hamm and he
basically offered me a job shortly after
and he interview and I was like that
sounds cool and I ended up working for
estream for about
year running their production services
so I was basically managing everything
having to do with with their live stream
technology at the time with event event
based stuff so were you able to stream
to a content delivery network yet while
you stream was a conceptually they
wasn't was their own CDN it was their
own so yeah so as you stream was a
technology enabler for live streaming
and it was it was a it's basically like
twitches today soap which was justin TV
which was the competitor of ours back in
the day and the Ustream existed for many
years actually before IBM finally bought
them out like two years ago so they
still go check it out the technology
still exists but they are now IBM and I
definitely had the coolest job at the
time because my role was to basically
since I understood how to stream I would
take there you know I would take our
platform and go to locations and stream
an event so for example I dingo was like
putting out a new Mafia Wars thing and
they wanted to blow up an armored truck
in the middle of the Nevada desert so we
needed to livestream that and it was
gonna be live stream into the game
somehow so this is like a really
high-profile thing at the last minute
they say oh also we're gonna have Snoop
Dogg come out and actually push the
button to blow up the truck like cool
and so they sent me out to basically be
the the the producer for this thing and
we're on the middle of nowhere they have
30 40 miles outside of Las Vegas where
there's very little cellphone signal but
that's the only way we were able to
actually get the yeah video back was
using these these lobby backpacks
yeah and back in they existed back then
but they were you know they were they
were they worked quite well but you know
mounted data we're pushing was much
smaller than today yeah and yeah and
then we had snoop come out and I don't I
had to mike him up and everything and
and then he you know there's the
countdown and he pushed the button and
them armored truck blows up and fake
money goes everywhere um anyway so that
was that kind of stuff then there was
the one weekend a tour also with the
Sports Illustrated Swimsuit models so
they were basically flying from New York
to Las Vegas and we had a live stream
them doing a bunch of events so they had
as the person who was kind of the
interface between the client and and
their own people so just you know it was
a whirlwind year of experience but I you
know I I'd say I really got my chops
into live streaming as a result of my
time I used a just a general idea of
live streaming today is just so much a
part of our nomenclature especially in
Silicon Valley but then when you look at
other parts of the world that still have
don't even have access to devices and
the internet they still have no idea
what this is this kind of reminds me of
what it was like 10 years ago when you
guys are like talking about
live-streaming and other people are like
what is that right and so it's like the
path of technological development in
just 10 years is now multi-camera
livestreams 2 to 3 CD ends no problem
yeah right like this is crazy the pace
that these things are moving you can see
Ron's set behind Ron and all the old
tech that he still has from 20 plus
years ago and what we have now that's
just moving so so fast and you one of
the things that we also want to make
sure is that when people learn skills
that those skills don't obsolete like if
you learn how to spend a year at Ustream
learning about how that technology works
at least some of the skills can be then
taken with you and apply to future live
streams and productions so but if you
learn just a specific tool like if all
of a sudden Adobe Creative Suite ended
up not existing anymore so many people
that know how to use premiere and
Photoshop and all these tools would have
to go and relearn how to use other tools
there be some carryover but these are
the things that we want to make sure
that people are filling their their
essence with that can actually be
applied into later stages just because
tools expire so fast technologies expire
so fast now with these periods and you I
also just want to mention what the with
the lunch meats that you were doing and
stuff it's really interesting to be able
to do things like look back and see how
people behaved like for like 10-15 years
ago it's not saying that their ethics
from 10 or 15 years ago are the same as
they are now because they're definitely
not their humans they've evolved 10 15
years as humans but you can still go
back and enjoy
I actually highly recommend people that
video has like 15,000 views it should
have millions of views because people
should be interested in how people
behaved back then that are running a
company is as big as they are now so how
about the flying robot International
Film Festival so you kind of did video
production live streaming droning you
got into droning and you had a cool
video actually at a the drones eye view
of the world on your on your channel one
of them was Burning Man in 2013 which is
really beautiful video you've also taken
videos of things like the Mission
District here Iceland Cleveland Portland
all these different cities as well and
then I guess you got so into droning
that you were like I'm gonna start an
International Film Festival around these
flying robots yeah yeah yes so it's in
2013 I I was at an event and I saw a
friend of mine who had the had a drone
shoot a video and later you know I was
there at the time and he was flying in a
flying drone and capturing the footage
and I remember seeing the video later
and being blown away by the simplicity
and beauty of what he was able to do
with it
and like I gotta get myself out of this
and so I end up getting a drone in 2013
and back then you know it was way
different like there things were not
integrated into a cohesive system like
they are now so back then you could buy
a drone that could fly but didn't have a
camera on it it didn't have telemetry it
didn't have it could stay in the air and
could come home that was the two biggest
features or the the original DJI phantom
one so this is the white drone yeah you
know the little legs on it and so that
one that's what I ended up taking the
Burning Man that year to take that
footage how did you attach a camera this
so that so back in those days the way
what you had to do is you had to get a
GoPro and you had to put it on you if
you wanted stable footage you would put
it on a gimbal so a motorized gimbal
which again these things are you know
you've got the handheld ones in James
but the time these were third-party
Gamble's that you had to basically wire
on to onto the drone yourself and then
you have to balance it with a camera and
make sure
it would you know be bounced correctly
so that the putting should look okay
and then not only that once you have
that all set up there you still had no
way of actually seeing the video on a
screen while you're flying he's kind of
yes it yeah which is exactly what I did
at Burning Man I had agenda of being
great yeah and and then so then the next
thing to do was to add that on so you
end up adding a video transmission
system with just the video how the GoPro
and sends it down to a receiver that you
can see while flying now that stuff is
all integrated subsystems but back then
yeah you had two pieces all together you
had to know how to solder you had to
know how to you know go down rabbit
holes or forums to figure out how to
troubleshoot things and and you know and
I've always loved doing that kind of
stuff so it was it was a fun challenge
for me I mean I immediately found other
people who are doing the same thing and
yeah briar said brought it out to
Burning Man 2013 did that video got a
million and a half years I think in the
first week on YouTube yeah I kind of
blew it up and I go maybe there's
something here maybe I should do more of
these you know I you know any of my
videos would not got me anything
anywhere close to the views of that one
have gotten but it definitely opened my
mind up to the possibilities and you
know had me go down further oh and then
yeah so the film festival came out of me
wanting to you know to see more of this
stuff like III you know I had done my
own but I knew that there are other
people who are creating lots of lots of
drone videos and we didn't have a drone
Film Festival in the West Coast yeah
okay I want to start my own and so I
started flying robot and then basically
opened up submissions to anybody who
wanted to submit from around the world
and made it free or super cheap free I
think at the beginning and and it's
still very inexpensive I think's like 10
15 bucks per is the last fee that we
would charge you know for the last us
although he had done but yeah did that
did it three years in a row
thousand fifteen sixteen seventeen and
it's been on hiatus since buddy coming
back I do want to bring it back but you
know like I want you to bring him back I
know a lot of people want me to bring it
back I definitely inspired to bring it
back but the realities are you know
sponsors funding that's right hard work
yeah and and and finding other people
who are willing to
and the project and what should DJ I
let's get him to responsible DJ I was a
sponsor to year for the second festival
but they they were they weren't a money
sponsor and that's the thing a lot of
people are willing to give you dear but
I found after the first year was hard to
get people to actually call up cash so
finding getting that kind of dialed in
more because there is a real you know
actual cost involved for any puzzle you
know even though it is a very lean
festival compared to some other film
festivals around the world you know we
do it at the Roxy theater here in San
Francisco it's just fairly inexpensive
the the platform to process everything
on is basically free and you know Eddie
next time you need some money right you
just come see me I got a guy you got a
guy alright what do I got a what I got
to give up for that don't worry about it
just let me know I'll take care of it
we'll get you a festival all right
sounds good it's definitely out
something like a VC would want to fund
and it's not something I would want to
take me seed funding for because like
there's no way you're gonna take a Film
Festival and make it you know into like
cut into like fun dancers oh yes yes I
start to Pauly
talk to you Pauly Pauly Pauly Shore yeah
alright you're trying to make a but
nonetheless yeah I definitely love the
gear going but it's it's at this point
it's likely it's not gonna happen this
year we'll have to reevaluate whether
it's gonna happen next year I would love
for to happen again next year and I'm
definitely thinking hard and fast about
it and we'll certainly make an
announcement it's gonna even want it all
happen awesome and hopefully there are
people that are either watching or that
are involved in the space that want to
help make flying robot film festivals
happen around the world I think that's
it's a great idea I love the federated
yeah let me great it's a great idea
you're like you said it when you first
can see the perspective of the drone
that's flying while you're flying it
you're like oh my god there's so much
more to life than just my be me being in
my body and slowly and then that
Awakening is so valuable and then if you
can make it into fun games that people
can play fun videos that people can make
and actually we have the winner of the
2017 yes I would say so
you're kind
good point here where posit sorry so you
know the the the perspective and the fun
aspect of drones also leads to drone
racing which is very popular yeah we've
got categories to that in the festival
for a while now but drone racing gives
you that you just quickly drone racing
basically is you're wearing goggles and
you're flying the drone as if you're
sitting in the copy of the Kosh
which is way different than standing on
the ground with it with a hookin screen
and you're doing a line of sight you're
like in VR environment and the
perspective of the drones it's not quite
true we are but it is it is that it does
feel that way because it is you are
seeing camera input into your eyes
directly with everything else being
blocked out but it is kind of a mono
it's a mono signal right now but it's
amazing because you know if you look
there's tons of amazing if what's called
fpv first-person view
drone Flyers on the internet right now
so cool those videos are amazing right
these and these guys are so good at at
being able to fly and do do acrobatic
tricks and yeah and and I've we'll get
to this in a second but as a result of
that I've gotten to know a lot of these
drone these drone you know racers and
ended up starting a company with a few
of them called x-class and so we are an
organization that makes large-scale
drones for drone racing or weird
large-scale drone race leagues so we
have specs on how to build them and then
people build them and then we have races
that people come to and be a part of you
know so that's another tangent in the in
the drone role that I've kind of gone
down but anyway let's get back to the
creativity yeah that's beautiful
democratization of the drone
technologies for creative purposes yeah
fpv so cool yeah there's like people
that are flying in the Safari around
like totally and that's only growing I
mean as we gain quality of the cameras
and the yeah and the transmission
systems get better so what we're looking
at here shell describe please this is a
Bulgarian filmmaker who who created this
video which is the one best of show in
the last flying robot Film Festival as
well as
if he goes the LOL WTF category winner
so basically swept the awards that year
and it's a top-down view of this parkour
guy basically running across all these
amazing places in bulgaria and and you
know being very creative with it that
was a little little kind of video game
montage that's all this top-down
perspective and it's to music music is
pretty good in this and then the the
perspective kind of changes on you -
yeah it's like you're looking at it and
you always think it's a top-down sort of
thing but then occasionally
you'll see him do something different
and it takes you for your few seconds to
realize that it's actually not a
top-down view anymore it's actually a
side view side view yeah like we have
comms ability yeah but anyway it's a
brilliant it's a brilliant film it's so
good and never get bored of watching it
and I think this just kind of impetu
mises you know the creativity that you
can really do with what's possible it's
possible exactly yeah you know because
it's it's definitely it's it's good
traditional filmmaking combined with
acrobatics and you know they're here
this is the side side shadows talking
about - he's actually crawling up the
side off the side of a building yeah and
and it's framed upside down he's going
down I don't think but basically the
subject camera angle warping at 90
degrees Wow but since your mind is
already looking at its time ya kind of
think it's it's still the ground so
Eddie it's so important for us to get
this rebirth back so that people can
kind of crowdsource their creative ideas
and submit them into the film festival
and then have flying robots and all the
cool footage that has never been thought
of maybe creatively brought back to the
world like who would have who thinks
about things like this we need young
people submitting this type of stuff to
inspire us to have a different view on
reality yeah yeah well thank you it's
something it'd happen again so important
yeah
yeah we'll see how we can help we really
want to see this happen oh my god that
could yeah the coins right right there
there's so many interesting add-ons that
people can do I mean I think it's also I
think one of the challenges now too is
because drones and become so ubiquitous
and anybody can really buy one off the
you know off the shelf or
on Amazon or whatever you know it's not
hard to learn how to fly I mean
obviously being coming up with a
creative idea and doing something
interesting is the harder bar and that's
always fun to see what people can
actually do and so in some ways because
the ubiquity of the technology and tools
that offers a lot more about people the
potential to create something amazing
okay so that's great but at the same
time it's just a lot more [ __ ] content
that's also being created that's right
now and that's line it's totally valid
people should be able to create whatever
they want but it just makes it a little
harder to find I think that diamond
they're off sometimes oh that's 100% the
case we were just talking about that
with a lot of passion actually the
conversation between the democratization
that's happening with the exponential
technologies and the signal-to-noise
ratio that's happening so how do you
both enable the text to be democratized
to but then also keep stay very vigilant
with what signal what you consider
signal and making sure to uplift that
further into the world and that's a
great question now it's a great thing to
try and figure out because there's so
much noise that comes with the with the
platforms being completely opened up the
way that they have been so okay so and
so now we're talking like droning has
blown up so much that this has even made
the government the Federal Aviation
Administration trying to figure out how
the PUC they're gonna handle this it's
no longer the Wild West
yeah so teach us about what this is like
so in the early days there were really
no rules around drones specifically they
and you could pretty much get away with
flying anywhere and pretty much doing
anything as long as nobody got hurt
nobody really cared now there's a lot
more restrictions you can't fly there's
certain areas just can't fly at all such
as national parks airports airports or
both yeah the I mean there were there
originally where blanket no-fly zones
around airports if you were
you know a hobbyist or so but now as a
convert if you're a commercial pilot you
can get authorization around certain
parts of the airspace so it's become a
bit more nuanced and a bit more dialed
in so if you use let's say need to do a
shoot you know east of the Oakland
Airport or something like that if it's
like maybe a half a mile away you could
probably get authorization to do it
because it's not gonna be right in the
flight path yeah yeah but there's an
automated system now that basically
creates kind of a segmented zone around
every Airport every major airport and if
you're within a zone that isn't directly
affected by the flight path and your
commercial pilot we can usually get
authorization for it but it's taking a
long time to get to that let's see but
and obviously for good reasons obviously
there's a lot of people who are just you
know don't know what they're doing and
they're flying and you know getting
close to airplanes and you know as much
hikers there's been around drones
intersecting with airplanes
there's been maybe one and it's even
even unclear if that's even there was
one I think collision with a Black Hawk
helicopter something like that but
there's been no actual reports of an
airplane actually hitting a drone that's
been proven
there's been a lot of sightings and
things like that but but I it's not to
say that the danger is real
but I think the hype especially because
it's a new technology tends to become
greater than the reality of the actual
danger the nuance with the national
parks to will be important because yeah
you want people to naturally be able to
explore national parks without hearing
your above but also you want people to
that can't go to the national parks to
be able to watch a pretty beautiful
drone footage of that as well so yeah
the new yeah and so I mean and the
answer to that is you have a permitting
system and that's supposed to be what's
what's that happens with national parks
but they there is no way to get a permit
from what I understand they just they
just deny them blanket even though they
say that's the way to be able to fly in
a national park just to get a permit but
unless you're like National Geographic
or something like that that's it's
pretty much hard to make that happen
it happens if you get caught doing so it
depends on what you get caught doing if
you get caught doing something that has
created that's hurt somebody or created
danger where you're actually putting
people in danger then the FAA is gonna
be a lot more interested in
in what you're doing and they're gonna
likely want to find it you know they
have different levels of enforcement but
they they can certainly find you good
about hefty yeah I have to eat them out
yeah so we and people have been find it
definitely happens and from what I
understand enforcement supposed to
actually become more prevalent than it
has been up until now so I I think
that's good for the most part because
the government and regulators are
understanding are getting some of those
nuances they understand that drones do
have useful purposes we're not just
talking about filmmaking but we're
talking about search and rescue is
actually a huge one a lot of people's
lives have been saved
drones finding them out in the
wilderness somewhere no so you you so if
like in cases of maybe like avalanches
or like yeah okay so so you can kind of
like send a team of drones out to look
for humans with maybe like thermal
sensing or exactly yeah there there are
floor sensors thermal sensors so that's
definitely used to find heat signatures
of missing people so you know parent uh
elderly with Alzheimer's who go
wandering out you know leave their home
and they go wandering out the woods you
know who they are yeah that's half
there's been several cases where people
have been located who've know under
those conditions and then I was gonna
say Oh fires as well so forest fires
huge one you can kind of it's it's a way
to again for search and rescue but also
to to see from a bird's eye view where
fires are and structure fires especially
I think a lot of fire departments are
now wanting to have drones because they
can fly a drone over structure and they
can actually see with a hot spots or
they can if they can find out exactly
where to attack a fire well with a lot
more certainty than they could just by
looking from the ground yeah so so
that's becoming III predict within five
to ten years every fire department's
going to have a drone for that purpose
yeah in the amount of creativity that
has yet to be unleashed by the power of
drones being used in across all these
fields that you are listing this is
another one of the reasons why the I
think the flying robot Film Festival
needs to become more popular and and
around the world yeah and you'll have
all these different cases it's saying
you could have like an entrepreneurial
arm as well of people that are trying to
think about using drones for all these
different ideas that yeah yeah totally
and we have a category Jones for good
which is good it's exactly actually
highlight the positive uses one of our
one of our winners from first a second
year is a zipline and they are now one
of the largest nonprofit organization of
our nonprofit I think they are but they
they're delivering blood and medicine to
rural areas in Africa in varying
countries in Africa so you know a lot of
a lot of developing countries you've got
horrible roads and it'll take you know
hours to to get medical help so into a
village somewhere but with with what
what what zipline is doing in I think
Uganda and probably getting the
country's wrong but they've got a few
countries where they're where they build
these hubs these space ports and they
can just load up a bag of blood or
medicine in the payload of a fixed-wing
drone and they've got all locals that
are operating it - they train local
local people there to run them from
these things and they package them and
they can have that stuff delivered
within 30 minutes pretty much anywhere
so and then what about I feel like I
should ask you about this before we get
into the last video which is that what
are we what should we do about like the
ethics around and morals around how to
use drones for benevolent purposes all
right yeah using them for like
autonomous war and in them for all these
other things that are we consider a
moment sir yeah issues sure yeah what do
you think I mean in some ways I feel
like it's it's similar to most other
technologies that can be used for good
or bad I mean it's interesting because
drones I think you know in in in the
collective consciousness has been used
for for war fighting you know for war
and for killing people and for the US
government using to kill people and you
know
Afghanistan and in Pakistan and things
like that that's one use that I'm
definitely not a fan of and I would not
like to see that you know become its
primary use but at the same time is a
technology that can be used for
benevolent purposes and used for
nefarious purposes and like all
technologies that can be used in that
way I think they need to be approached
in a thoughtful manner and regulated in
the way that you know that promotes the
good over the bad and it also some moral
dilemma I mean obviously because you
know our own government is making drones
that are that can be used to kill I
think we as a people have to take a look
at that and say is this is this
direction we want to go and do we want
to or do we want to have an autonomous
war battlefield to it you know this is
this the future do we I mean the future
should be there are no wars right
obviously but yes but the reality is
that's probably not gonna be our near
future or deep work on ourselves and our
collective can potentially get us there
this is just a quick oh yeah the example
of the video of the barge that was
flying around the Golden Gate Bridge
airspace yeah so this is yeah this is a
recent actually over July 4th I was
asked by a shipping company to fly a
drone around this container ship that
was coming into port and there's four
tugboats that are shooting water cannons
around it it's kind of a salute to
America is how they were is how this
French company was what's up positioning
it but they unfurled these American
flags and the size of the of the boat
there and brought it under the Golden
Gate and so yeah I was tasked with
flying a drone around it and for anybody
was wondering at home this was not
launched from the surrounding areas
where you're where it is illegal to
launch from because it's all national
park area but it was launched from a
moving boat and so you can this is this
is totally legal as long as you're doing
it from not from it from a neutral area
such as the water the water yes it's
critical make sure you do not get in
trouble and actually if you if you uh if
you can I don't if you can scrub through
this wrong but if you get to the point
where it goes underneath the bridge I do
a fly around the other side of it in
that part
it's a little more interesting yeah so
you can kind of see the tugs there and
then we go under the bridge thank you
probably I play from here gosh those
things are masses they at camp we should
90% of all world trade happens by seeing
all of those containers are filled with
different materials from around the
world we have cars in there there's
goods from China plastics all different
types of some people recycle cardboard
back through those yeah it's pretty
crazy it's true this had just come up
from LA but I think it was destined for
yeah somewhere far east after that
things are insane yep it's great Ron
what you gonna just scrub a little bit
further there's I think once we get
underneath the bridge there I kind of
come around the front of the boat and
that's a little more interesting
here we go do a little see the little
show they got going on its first time I
had ridden on a tugboat before and that
was a lot a lot of fun so I was on
something someone to that yeah that
wasn't that didn't have water shooting
off of it and that was pretty rad
because the the boat not only was the
boat being used to Ferris out there to
you know to be able to fly the drone but
the it was a working tug so after we
were done with the shoot the tug
actually had to push help push this boat
into port in Portland I'm sorry in in
Oakland yeah Brooklyn and so there's the
experienced him oh it just jumped yeah
that's the end okay maybe I didn't get
the right one but that's that's right
the yes it's seeing what a working tug
does yeah it was pretty rad you know
I've never really seen that experience
but yeah basically the tug comes all the
way the very back of the boat kisses the
back of the boat and they toss the line
down the tide line and basically the the
ship cuts its engines and the tugboats
are the ones that are kind of
maneuvering it in and so forth that's
yeah well yeah I get those small things
can move the big yep barge me there
those things have they have massive
engines and they have like giant
I don't know fins that go in the water
like they can basically there's they can
they can break like they can actually
take a multi hundred ton ship and
basically break it to almost a
standstill you know one or two Terry
interesting and very interesting modern
Genuity yeah and so then those go I'm
always on the beach at the beach at the
beginning as an ends of well the wave
trips so in the Bay Area they're
required to whenever a a commercial ship
comes into the Golden Gate you have what
are called pilots that meet them out
like eleven miles out or so before they
come into the gate and the pilots are
based in the Bay Area they go out they
meet the ship they actually climb up a
rope ladder onto the ship yeah and then
they take control the helm so they're
there they're the pilot command because
they have so much experience brings
barges in and out of the Cray it's a lot
of traffic there's there's you know
areas that are dredged in areas that are
not dredged and so they just know
exactly how to the right path to take to
get in and do a riot so yeah because
otherwise you've got you know we got
captain's that are obviously experienced
but they're not experienced with
necessarily with it without with a high
density area such as the bearings and
you know nobody wants to have a or
Singapore's also I'm sure yeah I'm sure
this is common with probably all boys
yeah and then what about the most recent
piece of content also that was very
recent but the this one too is very
interesting this is people playing
Dungeons & Dragons behind bars
yes yeah and you you see you also do
this creative video production as well
and it's interesting that you know I
also spent some time in jail and when I
did I had a good amount of of these
experiences where I found meaning in
these ways to build community around
around similar habits and you these are
like creative cooperative trying to take
the emotions of other people while you
play these games so I think this is a
very important piece of content and
you're also avid Dungeons and Dragons
I haven't played D&D in a while but I
certainly used to for when I was younger
yeah just the set up on that is the so
a friend of mine Elizabeth she's a
producer in a filmmaker for a lot of
documentary work and television work and
so this has been a passion project of
hers for a while to basically interview
prisoners in and out of the the
Californian jails and prison system
about their use of playing D&D and as it
turns out in certain prisons they do
this pretty pretty regularly and I mean
some prisons they've had the fight for
the right to do that because in some
prisons they see it as a form of play
and there's to take it all away but you
know the the the the big benefits are
you know collaborating community
understanding people having empathy you
know critical thinking all these skills
that once they get out of prison will
help them not go back into prison
ultimately right yes equally you know
they're they're playing when they come
out and they're making connections and
they're engaged in something that is not
what they did prior to getting thrown in
jail and I think in most most prisons
they're set up in such a way to be
punitive not restorative or
rehabilitative at least in this country
and so that's why we have such a high
recidivism rate in prisons is that you
know they come out and they've got
people have no idea what to do right
they they go back to their old ways
because that's what they know and so D&D
helps to in role-playing in general like
helps to give them another option or
give them something else to focus on and
it turned and you know it's I think it
remains to be seen but there's a lot of
evidence to show that that those that
are playing the indie and really get
involved in it don't go back to prison
you want to watch the video yeah yeah
let's do it okay there's D&D and nearly
every institution in California prisons
are the most segregated places in the
world the D&D table was one of the few
places where you could have blacks and
whites playing together I see a lot of
potential come out in people when they
start playing these games being able to
put themselves in someone else's shoes
I've been playing Dungeons dragons in
prison for 35 years I mean we we were
hardcore we'd play from
as soon as we come back from breakfast
to lockup
my name is Elizabeth I'm a documentary
filmmaker and the creator of let's play
a film about the controversy around
Dungeons & Dragons in the United States
Department of Corrections we used to run
underground games like with no books or
anything we didn't actually have the
actual books we had these photocopies
they took his dice I think and he sued
to get possession of his dice and
Dungeons and Dragons materials and his a
homemade 20 sided dice in the process of
interviewing and directing film shoots
they started to learn all about the
world of Dungeons & Dragons behind bars
Dungeons & Dragons is one of the few
activities that sprung up organically in
the prison system that's helping inmates
prepare for life on the outside its
creative its cooperative and it's a way
for inmates to express and explore
difficult emotions and trauma
vicariously through roleplay you have to
ask why we lock people up and if the
reason is for rehabilitation so that we
get somebody who's going to be better on
the other end then D&D totally fits with
that thank you so much for supporting
this campaign and for joining me in
asking does everybody have the right to
game yeah so this is a Kickstarter
project that just launched today for
funding this documentary on called let's
play DME behind bars
and so I I myself and Noll who is a
friend and partner from the secret ally
which is a space that I'm part of
created the video and yeah it's live now
so they're trying to fund it we've got
about a month to go but yeah if you just
just go to let's play or just go to
Kickstarter and look folks probably
links in there you know we'll put we'll
put the link in the bio for everyone to
go and check that out in you and back it
on Kickstarter so we can get like you
said decrease the recidivism or empathy
more cooperation more creativity you
there's so many studies of putting a rat
inside of a cage without any games and
then if you put a round side of cage
that has different of objects and things
to play with it's a neural
infrastructure actually blossoms and
architecture grows better than if it's
just constricted to nothing yeah so
it seems like common sense when you
think about it it's like if you if you
lock people up and you don't have them
have anything for them to do then
they're there kind of lose their mind
and how could I want to do anything and
if you do give them something to occupy
their brain or something you know that
allows them to to be functional in some
way then that's usually gonna be that's
gonna have a positive income a positive
outcome and the second chances become
more effective because they have went
through these exercises more yeah all
they said stuff less recidivism okay a
couple other questions on the way out I
mean I'm really excited for all your
future content that you're gonna be
producing yeah this type of stuff is
great let's play a D&D behind bars also
drone contents gonna be really exciting
in the future of lightroom actually i
kind of want to ask you about that what
is the future of video production Ron
and I joke quite a bit that at some
point there's probably not gonna need to
be an actual interviewer there's always
gonna be somewhat something that's
parsing maybe just a eyes talking
there's not going to be someone to be
the technical director will just be the
cameras auto-switching while people talk
there'll be just drones following you
while you go about I mean there's so
many of us day hope I'm dead before that
yeah what do you think about all these
different things sure so you just have
robots interviewing robots no no well
they have access to the Internet and we
have access to just our wetware of our
brain right I don't
yeah well and then also I mean with with
you know facial recognition scanning and
AI there's a plugin hidden stories about
how these datasets have been you know
being leaked into like the the Chinese
army or something about it being used to
basically train their datasets to
understand different faces you know I
could see that being you know what's the
stop what's one vision of the future is
that you've got robots to take on the
personas of people that they've learned
about through these data sets and then
other robots that are you know
interacting with them in some way
I mean I don't think that's a future
filmmaking well actually you know one
thing that's that's sort of interesting
I think in a controversial way right now
is this whole idea of deep fakes yeah
I'm just the ability which is
essentially the ability to create a
video with somebody in it that looks
in acts like the real person but it's
not that person at all and so it's
faking faking a video clip of somebody I
could see that being completely
detrimental to let's say an election or
something like that
Ruth right exactly well truth is already
compromised in so many ways but I mean
it seems like another really and another
way to make truth even less findable I
guess yeah anyway so my hope for the
future of filmmaking just as quickly to
sum up I think you know it's the
technology keeps evolving we get better
cameras we have better technology to
switch shots certainly to a better
editing technology and certainly AI that
can you know mix things up and it helped
with all that but ultimately at the end
of the day I think there needs to be a
human behind it to can direct that
creativity or tell that story because
ultimately any video content that's
being created needs to have a story
behind it and if you're not telling a
story even if it's five seconds like
what's the point yeah you know used for
benevolence and ethic ethical evolution
so that it's not used for malevolence
always everything's so important and and
hopefully that future is more creatively
enabling with these technologies
erupting easier to find the signal all
these types of things right Eddie
where do we come from beyond this 3d
reality do we come from somewhere else
into these earth suits to play on the
planet
you know I it's it's funny I've been
reading Michael Pollan's book recently
and I like his idea his his notion that
maybe it's maybe it's the mushroom
aliens that have basically sent signal
you know that humans have become have
grown from I know if it's his idea
necessarily but he talks about in his
book but that you know Apes or homo pre
Homo sapiens have evolved into Homo
sapiens because they ate some mushrooms
or something and then their brains
started to you know the stoned ape
theory yeah exactly it's not a thing so
you know maybe that but I don't know I
don't know if that's helped us because
now we've now you know a thinking
species that can that can basically wipe
out the planet so maybe that was
by the aliens but you know that's one
theory that it that we are just you know
that we we aren't you know maybe it's a
simulation maybe it's a maybe it's you
know maybe maybe it is it is you know
maybe it a bit maybe there's other other
beings that are you know that are
playing a game and we are merely I guess
I would make it a simulation with it I
don't know yeah I have no idea okay
sorry I think you you went across a lot
of really interesting points there you
touched on a lot of entries jumping
around I'm still learning I'm trying to
figure it out myself
yeah yeah likewise always a student of
the universe trip
trying to get to the ultimate nature of
reality is not just a physical planet
orbiting a star there is way more of it
that's deeper than this that exists here
that we're not just gonna don't just
stay at the surface get deeper yeah yeah
and if you can find in another dimension
to explore yeah go to you know or if I'm
in a different dimension then see what
that looks like even closing your eyes
and just expanding yourself out of your
own body is in itself just beyond what
is your normal five sensory experience
yeah of life it's true meditation get
you the psychedelic issue there's all
different types of ways up the mountain
connecting in nature all these types of
things can get you there agreed and then
how about do you think we're in a
simulation you know I used to think that
was an easy answer to say no but now I
don't know as I'm learning more I think
maybe I think it's a distinct
possibility that we could be or that we
are we are in a simulation and then we
are just mirror but we have some
autonomy as characters in the simulation
so maybe the the the stage and the
setting is simulated but are but but we
are just merely we're beings with some
limited amount of autonomy within that
world you know kind of like what's the
movie where
what's his name spacing right now where
what's his name any ideas are on them
movie like what are you yeah
whom I think I'm Jim Carrey okay Jim
Carrey plays the character he's that
he's who's like living he's basically Oh
Truman Show yes too much oh yeah maybe
this is great yeah like The Truman Show
is basically a setting your babies went
through our channels yeah yeah people
are flipping through in show all right
oh man that's a great aspect of that
conversational point as well agree and
then what do you thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world being alive
yeah
and tell us more why because if you're
not alive then you can't you can't
really appreciate nature and other
humans and and all the things that come
from that you know I mean who it's hard
to say because I've never experienced
what it's like to be dead yet so I I
don't know at least I don't not that I
can remember so I guess maybe that's
that's that's a very biased point of
view but I feel like being alive and
allowing other other beings to be alive
is probably most beautiful thing that
there is something rather than nothing
it's nice I love it thank you thanks for
coming sure thing else no good yeah yeah
huge thank you thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
below on the episode let us know what
you're thinking about all these
different fields we talked about talk
more to your friends families chorus
people online on social media about the
role of video and art and film and
drones and also taking it to cool places
like the prison system and being able to
make great content like that in
submitting to cool festivals like the
flying robot International Film Festival
help that grow help that explore and
also find the links the bio decom the
YouTube channel the Twitter page also
that link to the Kickstarter project
that will be down there to go check that
out
shout out to Ron Vargas for producing
and directing thank you very much Ron
and also support the artists
entrepreneurs organizations around the
world that you believe in spiritual
leaders support them our links are below
patreon PayPal cryptocurrency design
cool merch and get paid all that's below
and go build the future manifest your
dreams into the world thank you for
tuning in we'll see you soon
[Music]